the balconies have never looked busier
Italians seeking fresh air from the
confines of their home the strict
locked-down has restricted people's
lives beyond measure but this is Italy's
new normal
almost everyone now wears masks if you
don't it can cause visible panic but the
streets also seemed much busier today
the strain of two weeks in lockdown
perhaps showing no no no it's um
physically took a Pinot Grigio propio
conserve a volley soakin Sevilla de la
cosa credo Capernaum otaku power factor
units eg Java no sensor sensor want he's
a mass Karina adesso so no Bobby
delivered to an energy Reynolds and
cerebral its Yannick Italy has tightened
its locked down further in recent days
the military now deployed to enforce
measures and passengers temperatures are
taken at train stations with internal
travel now banned there are early signs
these measures may be slowing the virus
spread but as the number of dying
continues to soar positivity is dropping
pre-much
italians don't just adhere to social
distancing now it's instinctive outside
supermarkets cues are ordered and calm
supply chains have kept flowing shelves
have stayed full perhaps telling there
isn't even a term for panic buying in
Italian a bit of panic on day one we've
seen no evidence of people stockpiling
everyone seems to be doing their bit we
have however seen more people in the
street today than ever before which
suggests nearly two weeks into lockdown
people are finding it tough to stay
behind closed doors
Italy is leading Europe's lockdown with
dignity but it's hoped other countries
will be spared the same pain
Sally Lockwood Sky News